ein gewöhnlicher mittag am bahnhof zoo
obdachlose warten von der
bahnhofsmission auf kostenloses essen
eine dusche oder einen neuen haarschnitt
einmal pro woche schneidet die gelernte
frisörin und franziska deren ansicht die
haare aber nur um die frisur geht es
hier nicht
eigentlich brauchen viele von dem glück
jemand der den arm nimmt
derzeit hat und zuhört und für manche
werden sie sagen sagen wenn mama zünder
oder oder auch wenn du doch meine mutter
wäre dann würde ich ganz anderes leben
draußen riecht nach urin schnaps und
schweiß
drinnen in der friseur ecke von
franziska winter nach haarschaum und
pflegen
manche kunden haben sich lange nicht
gewaschen stinken
andere haben wir leute liter beisetzung
in dessen funktion zur verbrauchs ich
habe da kein
früher arbeitete als journalist doch
dann wurde er krank verlor seinen job
vor drei jahren die wohnung anschluss
schenk franziska hinter ihm sorgen
köpfchen
ihnen solle seine nöte empfehlen denn
die nicht da ist immer schöne freundin
den krieg bekommt sondern die guten
gespräch mit ihm geben und nehmen in die
österreichische hawks und salzstock
scharf
auch franziska güntersleben stand schon
auf messers schneide
früher hatte sie ein eigenes häuschen
mit ihrem mann und ihren zwei kindern
ein schwerer autounfall änderte alles
aus dem schicksalsschlag hat sie gelernt
also ist seine heilen ist schlimm
das liegenbleiben ist noch schlimmer
aber dass nun wieder auslosung
allerschlimmsten ohne den unfall das
wäre nie auf die idee gekommen
obdachlosen ehrenamtlich die haare zu
schneiden
meine hände geblieben sind und das ist
meine aufgabe und in der liebe gott ein
paar jahre gibt lange winter hat
nachgerechnet mehr als 11.000
bedürftigen hat sie schon die haare
geschnitten und es können noch viele
mehr werden